Çeviri: Nadya Alasad
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Üç buçuk dakikalık bir internet videosuyla
bir müzik videosuyla...
sizlerin karşısına çıktık
ve popüler olduk.
Şimdi hep anlatmak istediğim
bir şey vardı...
Bu üç buçuk dakikalık müzik videosu
popüler olmamızı sağlarken
sanatçı olmamızı da sağlar mı?
Bakış açısına bağlı. Sanat çok
evrensel bir değer.
Lakin nereden baktığınıza bağlı.
Biz Berk ile birlikte müziğin içine doğduk
ve Berk 8 yaşında gitar çalmaya başladı.
Ben de ondan görüp gitar çalmak istedim.
Sonra akorları, her şeyi,
kendim deşifre ediyorum.
Sen başka bir enstrüman çal, aynı
evde iki gitarist olmaz dedi.
Piyano'ya yöneldim.
Rus ekolünden gelen bir hocam vardı
biraz sinirliydi...
ve piyanodan vazgeçmek durumda kaldım.
Sonrasında keman çalmaya başladım.
Aslında hayatımın enstrümanını
bulmuş oldum, keman.
Hayat bir dengeydi, keman çalmak için
dengede durmak gerekiyordu.
Ve 15 yaşında keman çalmaya başlayınca
lise hayatım,
Pera Güzel Sanatlar Lisesi
birincilikle bitti.
Geldik konservatuvar sınavlarına
üniversite çağına.
Konservatuvar sınavına
tam girmeye yaklaşırken
Kemal hocam, Cihat Aşkın dedi ki;
"Dünyaca ünlü bir keman virtüözü
Shlomo Mintz önderliğinde Ortadoğu'da
Telaviv'e yakın bir köydeki busta
keman workshop var".
Master classa gideceğiz ve orada keman
çalacaksınız dedi.
Tamam, yatıyorum keman, kalkıyorum keman,
keman çalıyorum,
çok seviyorum keman çalmayı
bütün hayalim keman çalmak üzerine kurulu.
Hayatımı bunun üzerine aslında ilerletmek
istiyorum.
Gittik ve ben oraya gittiğim zaman,
durdum, dedim ki;
''Ben keman çalmayacağım galiba
çünkü benden yaşça çok küçük
Japon, Alman çocuklar
Mendelssohn keman konçertosu çalıyorlar.
Klasik müzik dinleyenleriniz vardır
Mendelssohn keman konçertosu çok zordur
ve gerçekten benden yaşça küçük çocukların
o keman konçertosunu çaldıklarını görünce
kendime güvenim gitti.
Bu bir hayal kırıklığıydı,
bir başarısızlıktı, mutsuzluktu.
Ve kendime aslında başka bir çıkış
yolu bulmam gerektiğini düşünmüştüm.
Gel gelelim iki buçuk ayın sonunda
ben tabii konser biletleri
satmaya başladım
keman çalıyorum ama kendime.
Sadece kendime çalıyorum.
Sonra dedim ki;
ben konser biletleri satayım
bir şekilde konserleri takip edeyim.
Shlomo Mintz dedi ki;
çıkış yolu ve bu yol haritasını
gösterenlerden biridir.
Şarkı söylemek isteyen var mı? dedi.
Ben hemen el kaldırdım
ve bir Azeri türkü söyledim,
Akşam Mahnısı.
Bunu söyledikten sonra
herkes sessiz bir şekilde durdu baktı
ve ben dedim ki, ''Eyvah keman çalamadım
şarkı da söyleyemedim galiba'' dedim.
Sonra aynı Amerikan filmlerindeki
gibi, o sahneleri çok severim.
Böyle bir alkış koptu
ve herkes sesime hayran bir şekilde
Shlomo Mintz bana dedi ki;
''Sen keman çalma, şarkı söyle.''
Öyle demedi tabii.
Keman çalmaya devam edebilirsin dedi.
Fakat 18 yaşındasın ve ses eğitimi için
çok uygun bir yaştasın
lütfen İstanbul'a döndüğünde
konservatuvarın
ses eğitimi bölümüne gir'' dedi.
Geldik, konservatuvarın ses eğitimi bölümü
ve konservatuvar sınavlarına hazırlandım.
Türk Halk Müziği, Türk Sanat Müziği
napolitenler, aryalar,
çok çeşitli bir repertuvar hazırladım
ve jüri'nin karşısına geçtim.
Alaeddin Yavaşça, Selahattin İçli, Erol
Uras çok değerli hocalarımız var.
Sonradan Türkiye'nin çok iyi bir tenoru
Erol Uras dedi ki;
''Kızım sen bir enstrüman
çalıyor musun?''
'' Evet hocam çalıyorum
keman çalıyorum, hocam'', dedim.
Dönüp, yanındaki hocalar dedi ki;
''Efendim ağır şey çeker gibi
yay çeker gibi şarkı söylüyor
değil mi?'' dedi ve orada
Shlomo Mitz söylediği o cümle
benim konservatuvarı kazanmama
sebep oldu aslında.
İyi ki de ses eğitimi bölümünü seçmiştim
ve bunu söyledikten sonra
bu diyalogtan sonra
ben bile tutup ses eğitimi bölümü
sınavında keman çaldım.
Sonrasında ağustos ayı,
İstanbul Teknik Üniversitesi Maçka Kampüsü
konservatuvarın olduğu bina,
bir yokuş var yokuştan aşağı indim.
2000 kişi müracaat ediyor ama
sadece 12 kişi alıyorlar.
Koştum, cama baktım bir kağıt ve
kağıdın en üstünde Öykü Gürman yazıyor.
O kadar heyecanlandım
ve o kadar duygulandım ki.
Ne kadar doğru
bir yerde olduğumu hissettim
hayatımın dönüm noktalarından biriydi,
konservatuvarı kazanmıştım.
Bu okulu ya 4 yılda bitireceğim
ya hiç bitiremeyeceğim dedim
çünkü hep Flamenko dinliyordum.
Ve terennümler, Düm Düm Tekteler,
ten Nadir Nadi düm tek tekte
nadir, nadu, düm tek tek...
Sürekli terennüm halinde dedim ki;
flamenko dinliyorum
ve halk müziğini sanat müziğini
Flamenko ile birleştireceğim.
Konservatuvarı bitirdikten sonra
okulu da birincilikle bitirdim.
Bir 4 yıl kadar müzik öğretmenliği
yaptığım yuvada.
Ama çok tereddütlerim vardı
çünkü yetmiyordu
ve bir şey yapmalıydık
ve hayalimiz aslında bizim kültürümüze
ait olan türküleri ve şarkıları
Flamenko müzikle birleştirmek
aslında flamenkonun da
bizim halk müziğimiz olduğunu anlatmaktı.
Berk askerden döndü,
Sevilla'da yaşamıştı üç buçuk yıl kadar
dedi ki; ''Öykü Muhsin Bey diye
bir film var
Uğur Yücel ve Şener Şen oynuyor
orada Uğur Yücel, Şener Şen, Uğur Yücel'e
Evlerin Önü Boyalı Direk
türküsünü söyletiyor,
gel bunu bir yapalım.'' dedi.
Hay hay dedim, yaptık
ve 20 milyon tıklandı.
Aslında o üç buçuk dakika ile
meşhur oldu bu kız
oradan yürür dediğinizin altında
gerçekten çok uzun bir çalışma emek var.
Ve biz türkü yaptık, konserler, ün, şan,
şöhret, para...
Harika, harika, her şey çok
harika gidiyor.
Sonra Popüler Kültür bize dedi ki;
2. bir şarkı yapmanız gerekiyor.
Türküyü yapmıştık ya
sanat müziği de yapalım dedim.
Seni ben unutmak istemedim ki'yi yaptık.
O zaman da harikayız,
yine ün, şan, şöhret
her şey çok harika, fakat derken
şarkının etkisi azalmaya başladı
ve duraksama dönemi başladı...
2011-2012-2013
2014 yılında telefon çaldı.
"Öykü hanım, yapım şirketi arıyor
Urfalıyam Ezelden diye bir dizi var,
orada şarkı söylemenizi
türkü söylemenizi istiyoruz
aynı zamanda
konservatuvar mezunu bir kız, dedi.
Iş buldum, dedim iş buldum.
Konservatuvar mezunu bir kız oynayacağım
ve idealist olarak yapmak istediğim
her şeyi yapacağım, türkü söyleyeceğim
uzun hava söyleyeceğim...
O kadar çalıştık, emek verdik
dizi 11 bölümde bitti.
Çünkü yapım şirketi ve kanal karar verdi
dizi bitti.
Gel gelelim, yine bir hayal kırıklığı
ama yine vazgeçemiyorum hep devam ediyorum
hep devam ediyorum,
üretmeye, çalışmaya, sabretmeye,
ahlakımı bozmamaya
duruşumdan ödün vermemeye,
hep devam ediyorum devam ederken
bu arada bir albüm yaptım.
2014-2015-2016-2017 telefon çaldı.
Yapım şirketi. Biz proje yapıyoruz
Sen Anlat Karadeniz Projesi...
Aman Allahım. Ve orada,
''Şive yapabiliyor musunuz?''dedi...
Dedim, ''Yaparım yaparım
şive yaparım'', böyle konuşuyorum
ama ''şive yaparım,''dedim.
"Oy nenem yarabbi!" dedim.
''Oy nenem yarabbi!''
Ondan sonra, bir audition metni var.
Tabii ki şirkete davet edildim
ve deneme çekimi yapacağız.
Bu karakteri oynayıp oynamadığı mı
test edecekler
çünkü çok ağır bir sorumluluk.
Tabii karakter şarkı da söylüyor,
çok mutluyum.
Şirketten içeri girdim, dedim ki;
''Evet ezberimi yaptım, her şey çok iyi
çok heyecanlıyım.
Ben çünkü işini aşkla yapan
insanların heyecanını ölüyorum.
Bende onlardan biriyim.
İşimi aşkla yaptığım için
çok heyecanlanıyorum.
Çalıştım, yapacağım,''dedim.
Bir baktım Osman Sınav.
Osman Sınav karşımda.
Ama o bilgeliğiyle ve öğretici yanıyla,
o babacan tavrıyla, o kadar
beni rahatlattı ki.
Bana inandığını söyledi.
Ve "3 2 1 kayıt" dedi.
Ben oynadım, türkü söyledim.
Sonra, audition bittikten sonra,
saat 2'de girdim oraya,
çıktım saat 7'de.
Yani şizofrenik bir durum, size anlatamam.
Gülüyorum, ağlıyorum.
Bir sürü duygu geçişleri yaşıyorum
ama kendimi kanıtlamam lazım
Osman Sınav'a.
Ve sonrasında, oradan ayrılırken dedim ki;
"Bana olmadığını iki gün içinde
söyler misiniz" dedim.
Neden olmadığını söylemek istedim
çünkü o zaman daha çabuk arıyorlar.
Aradılar, telefonum çaldı.
Çok heyecanlıyım.
"Acaba rolü aldım mı? Asiye Kaleli
ben mi olacağım?" diye...
Menajerim dedi ki;
''Bizim Asiyemiz sensin.''
O anda bir çıkış noktası
ve benim için de dönüm noktasıydı.
Sizinle bunu paylaşmak istedim
çünkü ünlü olmak değil,
önemli olan iz bırakmaktır hayatta.
Ben hep üretmeye devam ettim,
hiç yılmadım.
Ve popüler kültür elbette gelip geçici ama
bıraktığınız ses, bıraktığınız iz kalıcı.
Aynen şarkılar gibi.
Öyle zannediyorum ki
bir tiyatro perdesinde, böyle bir perde de
böyle bir sahnede, eğer hoş seda
bir ses, bir iz bırakabilirsem...
Gerçekten ne mutlu bana.
Önemsediğim bir hikâye var.
Picasso'nun hikâyesi.
Picasso bir gün restorana girer
ve şef garson onu tanır.
Der ki "Torunlarıma, çocuklarıma, yadigâr,
hatıra kalması için
bir şey çizer misiniz?" der.
Bir kâğıt uzatır.
Picasso kırmaz, o kâğıdı alır
ve 5 dakikada bir şeyler çizer
ve kağıdı uzatır, der ki "Bin dolar.''
Şef garson da der ki,
"Aman efendim, ne bin dolar?
5 dakikada çizdiniz.
Yani, bin dolar olur mu?"
Picasso hazır cevaplılığıyla bilinen
bir ressam, döner, der ki,
"Sizin o 5 dakika dediğiniz
40 yıl artı 5 dakika."
Dolayısıyla, o üç buçuk dakika dediğiniz
müzik videosu, yaşım çıkacak ama
üç buçuk dakika artı 35 yıl.
Shlomo Mintz'ten sonra
Osman Sınav çıkışı yoluydu.
Benim için yol göstericilerimdi.
Ve üçüncü bir kişi daha var.
O da dünyanın 500 sanatçısının
arasında yer alan
ressam Mehmet Uygun.
Ben de böyle bir hava,
işte Sen Anlat Karadeniz'de
söylediğim türküler, 50 milyon tıklanmış.
Toplamda 250-300 milyona yakın
bir dinleyici kitlesi olmuş
ve her şey çok tıklanıyor.
Ün bende, popüler kültür bende.
Harika bir sesim var, oyuncuyum.
Bülent İnal'la başrol oynadığım
Urfalıyam Ezelden'de.
Şimdi Sen Anlat Karadeniz dizisindeyim
diye bir hava içinde.
Mehmet Uygun'un misafiri olduk.
Mehmet Uygun dedi ki;
"Ben sizi tanımıyorum
çünkü ben televizyon izlemiyorum" dedi.
"Ben popüler kültür...
''Ben gece kalkıp
resim yapıyorum" dedi bana.
''Ha'' dedim, ''yani işte, biz de..
bu yani...''dedim.
Ben de aslında çok çaba sarf ediyorum.
"Sanat nedir, Öykücüğüm?" dedi.
Birbirimize bakıyoruz...
"İnsanı insana insanca anlatan bir kavram
ama bunun üzerine
çok da konuşabilirim, Mehmet Bey" dedim.
"Bir dakika, bir dakika" dedi.
"Google'a aç" dedi.
Ben gittikten sonra bunu yapar mısınız?
Söz verin ama bu anlatacağım şeyi.
"Google'ı aç" dedi.
"'Art world' yaz" dedi.
Sanat dünyası İngilizce.
Yazdım.
"Görsellere tıkla" dedi. Tıkladım.
"Ne çıktı?" dedi.
Vango, Picasso, Leonardo Da Vinci,
heykeller, resimler...Aman Allahım harika.
Şimdi dedi, "Sanat dünyası yazar mısın?
Türkçe olarak," dedi.
Yazdım. Görsellere tıkladım.
Ne göreyim? Magazin dünyası.
Kim kiminle, nerede, nasıl, ne... şşşş...
Ne almış, ne giymiş, ne yapmış?
Sonra dedi ki;
"Öykücüğüm yorumu sana bırakıyorum" dedi.
Ben de yorumu sizlere bırakıyorum.
Teşekkürler. (Alkış)